how much of this tension is religious
in the Practical aspects of the courts
and the the evictions and the
demolitions and you mentioned something
Divine decree
how much underneath it do you feel
the division over religious texts and
religious beliefs
you know it's convenient to Market
what's happening in Palestine as a
religious conflict because it allows
um
The Listener the luxury of believing
that this is an ancient complicated
thing that stretches thousands and
thousands of years ago but the fact of
the matter is
the people who invented Zionism who
pioneered the Zionist movement who
called for immigration
and settling into Palestine a lot of
them were atheists
a lot of them
were not religious at all
um
and the leaders of the Israeli state
today a lot of them are atheists
and a lot of them are secular and so on
and so forth it's easy to it's easy to
say that this is
you know about Muslims and and Jews
fighting over the land and so on and so
forth but it's not it's about the land
itself and it's about
people being forced out of their homes